[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday April 4
Hank I think Maureen Johnson has a
special message for you hey um what is
my special message you just said I think
you're great and the Hummer thing do the
Hummer thing and let me tell you why let
me tell you why did you not Hank is
gonna take a Hummer for a ride and tell
the whole world
why Hummers suck H for Hank Age Hummer
this won't be in it'll be like one
second of my face and then back to John
talking about himself back to me talking
about myself
Hank several weeks ago commenter Peter
asked to see what it's like when I'm
working so I thought I'd show you that
so Hank today we're writing in a hotel
room look how pretty it is Hank I write
a lot with my friends Maureen Johnson
and Scott Westerfeld God that is a big
zit today we were joined by Justine
larval SD and Lauren McLaughlin and
Maureen Johnson's pet monkey mostly I
sit and look at the computer
see it's a non-stop thrill ride you just
saw me write like three new sentences in
my novel all of which I will eventually
delete I'm sure then after a while I put
stuff in my eye and then inevitably we
start talking know anything but my bald
spot anything but my bald spot I watched
about stories the best possible title
for the unauthorized biography I know
right yeah what's everybody's what's
yours didn't we have one for John
earlier guys do I look small is it
possible to have an eagle cancer then we
work for a while
and then we talk again
yes on yeah so kind of fun BiPAP of
being
like instead of a cone or skirt well I
mean this if you have insects dancing
and love being shared by something in
the middle of the light it's a being the
whole life but it does blah blah so it's
not gonna be it's more of a cone or a
skirt I got you kid I can't have you
can't have him dancing in a skirt like
the color but it's hard okay I'll handle
the floodlight yeah oh by the hem of the
floodlight skirt that's nice it's not
too all underskirt of light coming from
the floodlight do you really need these
bugs I'm like Princess Diana not afraid
to touch the leopard you nothing else it
closely
funky penguin 402 asks what will the
Looking for Alaska movie be Reagan
here's a more important question one
we'll be looking for asking Phoebe made
zombie hey relax a little principal
photography start so Hank that's how I
spend my days writing god it's not even
as it so much is it's a character flaw
Hank I'll see you tomorrow